it's a good day when one of the biggest
news stories is about a tweet that
didn't happen which you can add to the
Trump era wars that don't happen or the
Trump era collusion that didn't happen
either
over the weekend Poli Sci professor Ian
Bremmer tweeted this quote attributed to
President Trump
quote Kim jong-un is smarter and would
make a better president than sleepy Joe
Biden no joke you could almost hear
Trump saying that which is the problem a
bunch of hysterical anti Trump errs
believed it clogging twitter with
breathless outrage for a day later
Bremer said it was a joke and he took it
down he apologized problem solved but
here are a few lessons to turn this tiny
tiny story into a segment if a parody
doesn't offer a clue that it's a joke
then it's not a parody it's just
misleading unlike most media which
misleads on purpose by parroting actual
journalism and it's on Memorial Day
weekend which notes the sacrifices of
those who died for our country
one way to commemorate that is to make
sure in the future that your country's
blood is always treated as precious so
we must be doing somewhat better if our
military footprint seems to be shrinking
and that many of the wars among adults
are now over tweets two years ago we
worried about real missiles coming from
Kim now it's about fake tweets heading
toward him that's progress for now
anyway mm-hmm he apologized promptly I
think the problem was it was plausible
as he said one of my dear friends and so
I I was on globalist he's not though
he's a big populist oh is he
well I don't know like I'm not gonna
look I read his book and I want to throw
it against the wall because at the end
he was for non-intervention no my you
love war I believe in being the
policeman of the world I do but that was
the thing is that the thing I'd seen
earlier in the day was president Trump's
tweet yes when I saw that tweet I was
like oh yeah exactly
okay whatever but it also it could go in
my fans the book of fans is my fantasy
book not the book appear you have a
fantasy book that's better than this
[Laughter]
are you dressed up as a policeman tweets
I never sent oh yeah yeah yeah that is
the book they can also like do Twitter
it is Twitter yes exactly
Jesse I do feel safer now than I did
with North Korea you did I even with the
tweets I do and I think it's I think you
it's due to Trump's kind of nature of
dealing with separating the person from
the country so he deals with the person
which is what salesmen do right I just
think it's fine that these so-called
experts keep falling for hoaxes and then
they blame the hoaxes instead of
themselves yeah
these people aren't as smart as they
really are cracked up to be
think about everybody that's an expert
fell for Smollett fell for the Russia
collision fell for the dossier fell for
this it's like it takes two days or a
week of checking something and then then
then you get to the bottom of it but I
don't even go on Twitter anymore I
didn't go on Twitter once this week yes
I told you not to tweet anymore yeah
trying to help you that was the first
successful intervention that's ever it's
true we took a in the green room and we
said it is bone in 2015 did you yeah
it's right you are the twin who the
twitter cop you're not just an
interventionist foreign policy you're an
intervention and interventionist on
social media what there's you're been a
journalist for many years anything that
seems too perfect never is right
absolutely it's always more than the
story last of the story is that famously
say but I am a little surprised at this
conversation in that last week wasn't it
Trump supporters who put out what was a
distorted totally manipulated video of
Nancy Pelosi looking she's like she was
drunk and people in had to say hey this
is not real you don't need to distort
those videos they speak well no if used
to make if you slow him down Kennedy so
that she sounds like they were obvious
oh they're obvious well I think I
noticed
Democrats are complaining about
propaganda that's rich one oh yeah oh I
hear complaining about fake news
absolutely you kidding when people put
out stuff like the coz I think there's
people in their basement making a video
around the internet and that's why and
then Greg says here on the show oh he
feels safer when you have Trump
repudiating what his own national
security adviser John Bolton says
refuting be the prime minister Japan all
of them saying hey Kim is a danger in
from saying nah you know he's alright
didn't violate the IC he's playing chess
and they're playing checkers yeah I just
pointed right kennedy thoughts prayers
you're helping him Ian Bremmer is is
helping the president with tweets like
this and you never see the onion put up
a funny headline ago that's plausible
yeah the problem right it shouldn't be
plausible if it's parody if it's farce
it should be so incredibly outrageous
yeah the problem is he put something in
the realm of plausibility just to make
people like Anna Navarro and Ted little
see we told you he has to go wimpy
chable impeach impeach a beach you're
only helping him because the the biggest
problem is that people will continue to
divorce the president's actions and
personality from his policies and result
and the more that happens the great
divorce is CS Lewis called it the better
that presidents chances are and if you
run around saying everything he does is
just symptomatic of his insanity at some
point that stuff like oh yeah Kim
jong-un is right you know Joe Biden is a
low IQ fool you think what that's our
president you know that's bridging
differences one when you can agree with
an adversary you know can I make a shout
in Obama did the same thing over so I
want to make a shout out though I've
been ripping on CNN I
to complement Jake Tapper who spends all
Memorial Day basically just tweeting out
memorials of fallen soldiers and that's
the one area where you take the kind of
the cemetery formality and he
transferred it over to the
superficiality of Twitter so you can't
just stay on Twitter and pretend that
Memorial Day doesn't exist one of his
best one of Jake Tapper's best tweets
this weekend was he quit was quoting a
soldier who said be an American worth
dying for
mmm very inspirational I tried that
every day all right